[Music]
course you know the place where millions
of Americans end up every year after
making a large squirrel talk to CEO
of a coal company just center about
judicial system they are the backbone of
daytime TV the college student to bring
system mommy Judy don't get me preaching
up in here today you're watching the
verdict with judge Hatchett a show
that's making a difference you need to
be sober seven days a week for turn any
court I know cuz I'm not stupid
that you're a liar then and you're a
liar now the People's Court pack of dogs
draw blood this is a confession this is
a no dog I've had all my shots hot
now I know that looks like a fun episode
of hot bench but but you should know
that cute dog actually confessed to
murdering 14 people in the Pacific
Northwest so it's not quite as fun as
they just made it look but tonight we're
gonna focus on a type of justice then
you don't get to watch on TV and it
concerns immigration courts they're one
of those things you may not know much
about but are actually hugely important
to a significant number of people like
gefilte fish or the Insane Clown Posse
now in recent months you may have seen
multiple stories of ice agents raiding
workplaces and hauling people away and
while those stories are horrifying and
grab all the attention the place many of
those people end up immigration courts
are no less troubling there are around
sixty of them all over the country and
hundreds of thousands of people go
through them every year
pleading their case against deportation
so they are hugely consequential and the
stakes in these cases can be incredibly
high as one girl awaiting a hearing can
attest what'd happen if we sent you home
they're gonna kill me they're gonna
they're gonna kill me and they're gonna
kill my family that's horrible because
no child should have to worry about
whether they're going to be murdered the
biggest thing they should be worrying
about Oh are whether they can sit with
the cool kids while they eat their Tide
Pods and how they can please Slenderman
and that last one is obviously
ridiculous because remember kids
Slenderman already loves you just the
way you are
so this is a critical potentially
life-and-death process sadly the system
is a complete mess and don't take that
from me take that from multiple current
and former immigration court judges I
think most people would be incredulous
at what really happens in immigration
court and which sometimes passes for due
process our courts today are
dysfunctional in essence we're doing
death penalty cases in a traffic court
setting death penalty cases in traffic
court that is something we probably
shouldn't be doing in a place that we
definitely shouldn't be doing it like
having a cockfight in an emergency room
or doing coke in a build-a-bear workshop
it's a crazy idea it gets stuck in the
Bears hair it's completely inefficient
so so how did this system get so broken
well let's start with the fact that a
surgeon immigration from Central America
wrapped up immigration enforcement and a
glacial rate of hiring judges have
combined to create a truly massive
backlog of cases more than six hundred
and seventeen thousand immigration cases
are now backlogged that number has more
than doubled since 2009 the Mayo
Silverado it's as if they have forgotten
us is under this one of the watermelon
immigrants waiting for his hearing in
San Francisco where the average wait
time is three years in Miami the wait is
about a year and a half and it's much
worse in cities like San Antonio Atlanta
and Chicago that's true the estimated
wait time in Chicago is five years and
if you are stuck in that line that's not
good for your case because evidence for
your plane can become stale and
witnesses who could help you can
disappear or die and yet over 600,000
cases have piled up endlessly like Bed
Bath and Beyond coupons New Yorker
magazines and DVR'd episodes of Ken
Burns's Vietnam documentary yeah I know
it's good but I'm just never in the mood
and I never ever will be ever ever ever
ever but
issues the issues go much deeper than
just long wait times because while
immigration courts have the trappings of
a criminal court you can wind up there
from an arrest you can be detained
awaiting your hearing and you're arguing
against the government there are
actually civil courts because this is
not a criminal trial their only task is
deciding whether or not you can stay in
the country that's it so a lot of things
that you might assume someone in these
courts would have access to they don't
and the first big one is this
unlike Criminal Court in immigration
court the federal government is not
required to provide lawyers to
defendants who cannot afford them
exactly if you can't afford a lawyer you
have to defend yourself which is clearly
a terrible idea
think of an immigration hearing like
surgery you can try and do it yourself
but if you ever want to see your
family again maybe try and get a
professional to help you and troublingly
only 37 percent of immigrants in these
courts have counsel meaning the majority
of them are appearing in front of the
judge without a lawyer and some in
particular really need one many of the
undocumented children that walk into the
immigration court house don't have an
attorney and must represent themselves
there's children from two years old to
17 years old who are appearing by
themselves who are sitting there without
a clue about what's happening that's
just clearly ridiculous because you
cannot let a two-year-old to be
unsupervised in court you can't even let
her two-year-old be unsupervised in a
bouncy castle they're gonna come out
covered in glitter holding a broken beer
bottle and a dead bird how did they get
them in there who knows the point is
they can't be left alone for a second
and that bird has already been in their
mouth it just has you have to deal with
that reality and while sending kids into
court without representation might seem
crazy to you amazingly some judges are
apparently fine with it
because when a lawsuit was filed arguing
all kids need lawyers jack while an
assistant chief immigration judge
suggested that's not necessarily the
case I've taught immigration law just
literally two three-year-olds and
four-year-olds
takes a lot of time it takes a lot of
patience they get it it's not the most
efficient but but it can be done no it
can't
you can't teach immigration law to a
three-year-old you can't even explain to
a child that age the ELMO isn't his best
friend Elmo's not only a puppet he's a
celebrity he's never even heard of you
your relationship is completely
asymmetrical one immigration lawyer
actually put judge wilds whole three
year-olds theory to the test in what is
perhaps the single greatest mock trial
ever recorded and do you speak English
as your native language
[Music]
I like your balloon - what is your best
language where were you born
I read mommy in suits so do you feel
like you can go ahead and represent
yourself in immigration court to
determine your nationality uh-huh all
right are you excited to do it yeah of
course she's excited she knows all the
most important legal principles if I
like my balloon you mustn't deport soon
and if I place a tie over fairies
together with the asylum that lawyer
actually did a series of videos with
kids and they are all great but my
favorite is this one if you were removed
would you like to designate a country of
removal yeah okay what country would
that be
yeah oh yeah you laugh now but it won't
be so cute when that girl is deported
back to Papa John's because it's
technically pizza and that is exactly
why these children need lawyers but the
truth is whether you have a lawyer or
not your odds of success to a
frightening degree may be dictated by
where you are in San Francisco
immigrants are deported in 36% of cases
in Charlotte the number jumps to 84% in
New York City only 24% of cases result
in deportation in Atlanta the rate is
almost 90 percent I'm look while the
merits of every case are different that
is an alarming disparity between courts
normally the only thing that should
varied that much by region is the rate
of Jeff Dunham fans per capita and
regardless of where you are in either
case that number should never be as high
as 90% and the final quirk of this
system is that immigration courts are
not nearly as independent as they should
be because while you might assume that
they be part of the judicial branch
immigration courts are actually part of
the executive branch specifically
they're run by the DOJ making them
subject to shifting political priorities
so for instance right now the boss of
all these judges is this man Jeff
Sessions the only cabinet member allowed
to fly as a lap infant on a domestic
flight and he has made it pretty clear
what his priorities are for those that
continue to seek improper and illegal
entry into this country be forewarned
this is a new era
this is the Trop era you know it's a
very specific type of person who grins
when saying the words the Trump era it's
basically people with Trump's name
people with Trump's hats and the one
person in America is still getting a
kick out of cough FA hey I don't agree
with everything the guy says but boy we
had some laughs because it's not a word
confer fades not a word that that's why
it's funny
that's odds priceless
and sessions the thing is sessions has a
weird amount of power over immigration
courts he can refer cases to himself
which basically means stepping in and
personally reviewing decisions he
actually picked up a case recently
concerning a woman deemed eligible for
asylum over a year ago based on domestic
violence that she suffered four years
under her ex-husband in El Salvador now
if he overturns that decision not only
could that woman be deported but he
could also set precedents making it
harder for other domestic violence
victims to get asylum and while sessions
isn't the exact last person I'd want to
set precedents on domestic violence
he's pretty near the bottom of that list
right before Oh Jay Simpson Johnny Depp
and mr. peanut and if you don't know
what that last one is referring to just
Google mr. peanut domestic violence
honestly I have no idea what you'll find
but give it a try we might only surprise
the point here is when you combine all
of these factors backlogged courts lack
of representation and judges without
full independence you can have cases
that don't even seem to resemble justice
for example a few months ago the New
Yorker told the story of a woman from
Honduras who asked them to identify her
as Elena ms-13 killed two or third
brothers and shot her sister she fled to
America and turned herself in to border
patrol now DHS said that she didn't
qualify for asylum because she couldn't
prove credible fear of violence back
home so so she appealed requesting a
hearing with an immigration judge and
I'm about to play that hearing for you
in its entirety seriously this is the
whole thing I have read with the asylum
officer rhoads he told the asylum
officer that some gang member became
infatuated with you wanted you to be
with him wanted you to open a bank
account so the criminal proceeds from
the gang could be placed there and you
refused yes I said no did you move to
any other city in Honduras before coming
to the United States no the government
of the United States doesn't afford you
protection
for this type of reason I affirm the
asylum officers decision that was it did
you move no okay goodbye and thanks to
that hearing elena was deported back to
Honduras where she was assaulted at
gunpoint
by the gang member she had fled because
it turned out her fear was pretty
credible now we trimmed the
parts in that were a translator
interprets between her and the judge but
even keeping all of that in the full
hearing lasted one minute and
forty-three seconds there were only two
questions for context that hot bench
episode you saw at the start whether tog
had written a confession was 8 minutes
long and we counted 32 questions which
is absurd there should have been only
one question there how the did that
dog write this letter changed this list
and in some cases deportations do turn
out to be a death sentence take
Constantino Morales a Mexican police
officer was targeted by a drug cartel he
fled to the US and ended up in
immigration court in Nebraska he
couldn't afford an attorney so he
represented himself in court before a
judge who opts to deport eighty four
percent of the time Morales lost his
case and filmed this message after that
decision I'm being deported they are
deporting me it was four years of
fighting my request was denied but you
have to fight to the end don't be scared
no worries life goes on he was deported
back to Mexico and six months and 29
days after that decision he was killed
and that is heartbreaking
obviously so clearly this whole system
is broken so the question really is how
can it be fixed sessions has said that
he wants to hire more judges which the
system does need but he's also said that
he wants the judges to move faster and
advocated for increased scrutiny of what
he calls fake asylum claims which does
seem like the wrong approach because
immigration courts are a lot like sex
the way to improve them is rarely to say
hey let's do it a lot faster and meaner
and let's have Jeff Sessions overseeing
the whole thing
but the truth the truth here is we are
going to need big changes ideally the
biggest change would be to make the
courts fully independent from the DOJ
which is something that can't happen
overnight or under this particular
Congress probably at all
but at the very least we should
absolutely fix the stupidest problem of
all which is that nobody particularly
children should have to represent
themselves in these courts because
children do not understand the law
having them alone in a courtroom is a
terrible idea and to prove it to you I
give you the stupidest new court show
imaginable you've seen a lot of
corporate shows but you've never seen
one like this that's right in this
courtroom
everyone is three or four years old
everyone that is except that offended
what the is this a joke no this
isn't our bench and in this week's
episode this arsonist is in the hot seat
just objects object it's object not the
dot he's got the best legal advice
that's real rule can give that's the
difference between a banana of the cow I
don't know what what yeah
Todd Bench has everything a bailiff I
still not refer do you even know my name
I don't know who David Schwimmer has
David Schwimmer was not even impact our
Ridge ok the stenographers leaving now
a courtroom artist oh so there's a
sketch artist now great sure she's
terrible that's so good and of course
judge Riley how did you become a judge I
believed in myself to be a dead how long
have you been doing this
14 years you've been doing this for 14
years but you're four it's a case with
twists and turns
there was another judge what happened to
her she wet her pants and snacks so many
snacks well anyone share their snacks
with me you'll even see a lawyer turn on
his own client please just tell them
that I didn't burn down the hospital you
bring down that I did sorry you didn't
blow down to us oh and you know what I
am guilty all right there you go
I'm guilty god damn this small time back
is it stupid sure but is it any dumber
than how America's immigration courts
have run barely the judge sentenced me
to a jillion years I mean a jillion is
not even a number I mean this whole who
through that topic
you